bonsoir parce qu'elle écoute merci
d'être avec nous en direct sur rt france
à partir d'aujourd'hui donc les polonais
doivent obligatoirement se couvrir le
nez et la bouche dans l'espace public
avec des distributeurs de masques de gel
manifestement vous manqué de rien pour
vous protéger est ce que ça a toujours
été le cas ça a été le cas à ses tons
dans cette crise alors bon soit la
pologne a pris des mesures de
confinement et distanciation social dès
le 14 mars
les frontières ont été fermées
les vols internationaux ont été annulés
les trains à destination des étrangers
ont cessé de fonctionner et donc ça a
été une mesure qui a été prise
relativement tout en europe et qui a
suivi grosso modo ce que faisait les
voisins puisque je crois que ç'a
commencé en slovaquie aujourd'hui donc
la pologne peut envisager un
déconfinement assez serein puisque on le
disait il ya ces fameux distributeurs
automatiques gens sifflent
évidemment en tant que française parce
que évidemment ça nous fait un petit peu
rêver ça veut dire qu'on clair les
masques étaient en stock
des gens m'ont pologne ou alors ils se
sont fabriqué peut-être sur place
expliquez-nous nos ongles non non l'ena
n'était pas un stock toute l'europe a
été prise au dépourvu avec cette crise
du cornât virus
on n'était pas prêt on n'était pas plus
près que les autres simplement ils ont
pris des mesures
mais je dirais extrêmement fermé qui ont
été acceptées par la population sachant
que jusqu'à présent c'est la seule
méthode est trouvée pour limiter la
propagation et la diffusion du virus
étant donné le nombre de respirateur qui
lie en pologne
il fallait absolument éviter tout pic
d'épidémie pour saturer le système de
santé
oui pardonnez moi mais c'est ce qu'on a
fait précisément france un confinement
que les français respectent tout aussi
strictement à deux jours d'intervalle
avec la pologne
il n'empêche la france manque notamment
de masques mais aussi de test comment la
pologne fait pour s'en procurer de
manière massive
je suis pas particulièrement informées
pour vous répondre précisément sur ce
sujet ce que je vois c'est qu'on a des
cargos qui nous viennent maintenant de
chine avec une mobilisation de tous les
facteurs économiques qui permettent avec
un élan de générosité aussi de divers
d'associations qui permettent de
d'acheter entre guillemets des masques à
l'étranger et une mobilisation locale à
destination de fabrication je dirais
artisanales ou semi artisanale qui est
tout et mobiliser si vous voulez pour
pouvoir permettre à deux distribuer ses
marques à la population alors la
fermeture des écoles et des universités
ce sera pour vous en pologne jusqu'au 26
avril
quel est l'avis du médecin sur ce point
est ce que le retour à l'école aceto
assez prématurée est ce que cela vous
inquiète vous il
ça va se faire progressivement c'est à
dire que de tout va pas être mises en
oeuvre brutalement ici ils ont prévu des
étapes de confinement qui sont
progressives avec toujours une
possibilité rétroactive en fonction du
nombre de cas qu'il va éventuellement
augmenter aujourd'hui comment les
polonais accueille cette stratégie du
gouvernement avec une réouverture même
progressive des écoles assez tôt
comment comment les polonais le vie
parce qu'ils sont inquiets tout
simplement ils suivent les directives et
ils ont je dirais dans l'ensemble d'une
très grande civilité
il respecte il suffit de voir ce qui se
passe dans la rue ils respectent la
distanciation il m les matchs se ils
font les qu' il n'y a pas il n'y a pas
de ya pas de débordements merci beaucoup
parce qu'à l' écoute médecin généraliste
à varsovie d'avoir été avec nous